how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and
all things relating to the MCU the x-men
come into the MCU is something that
we've all been waiting for for a very
long time and now that Marvel and Disney
finally owned the rights to use the
x-men in the MCU it's only a matter of
time until they show up and we pretty
much know that in the beginning the
x-men aren't going to be introduced all
together in one big x-men film they're
going to be introduced individually and
actually show up in other MCU films at
first a great example of this is the
report that we got that Captain Marvel 2
is going to introduce rogue as a villain
along with rogue the Brotherhood could
also be introduced into the movie as
well and we also know that it's possible
that some x-men characters are going to
be getting their own Disney Plus shows
last week it was reported by Mikey
Sutton that Marvel Studios and Disney
are thinking about developing a gambit
Disney Plus show and now we have more
information on that and how it actually
is going to connect to Captain Marvel 2
and rogue if you're new be sure to
subscribe but notifications turned on so
you can stay up to date on everything
happening in the MCU and so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or ps4 so although fans were
pretty disappointed that we never saw a
gambit movie from Fox that was supposed
to happen with Channing Tatum there's a
little bit of hope restored with the
talks of Disney possibly developing a
gambit to Disney Plus show and like
Kevin Feige has mentioned with all
Disney plushies that are going to be
coming they're all going to be a part of
the MCU and tie-in to the films and
gambit is going to be no different today
Mikey Sutton is reporting that although
Fox toyed with the idea of turning a
gambit movie into a romantic comedy with
rogue Marvel Studios and Disney's plans
are going to be way different than that
the MCU is going to explore the romantic
relationship between gambit and rogue
however turning their relationship into
a rom-com is not in the cards in fact in
the MCU when gambit meets rogue she is
going to be the villain this falls in
line with previous reports stating that
in Captain Marvel 2 rogue is going to
make her debut as the villain rogue is a
classic Captain Marvel felt the two of
them have a very long history together
and the same thing goes for gambit and
rogues romantic relationship so
apparently in the MCU when we finally
see the two cross paths it's going to be
a love-hate vibe going between the two
of them
kind of
similar to a Batman and Catwoman type of
vibe a mutant hero falling for a mutant
bad girl and this certainly will be a
different dynamic than anything we've
seen in the MCU so far the biggest
relationships that we've had in the MCU
are Wanda and vision Tony Stark and
Pepper Potts who of course go on to get
married and have Morgan Stark Captain
America and Peggy Carter and of course a
little thing with Black Widow and Bruce
Banner but all for the most part we're
on the same team but with this
relationship it's going to be opposite
teams kind of like a civil war but with
that hate also comes love and according
to this report that is what Marvel
Studios and Disney are currently talking
about right now so if they do decide to
go with rogue and Captain Marvel - and
gambit it looks like they're going to
stay true to their classic comic book
relationship but let me know what you
think about this would you like to see
their relationship play out on the big
screen and who do you think would be
really good to play rogue and gambit let
me know what you think about that in the
comments down below and as always don't
forget to subscribe so you can stay up
to date on the MCU and follow me on
Twitter for live updates as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof